opportunist there were primaries all
over the country last night and great
news the Trump train is still full of
coal and belching black smoke into the
air all over the heartland including in
the home state of 2012 Trivial Pursuit
question MIT Romney MIT Romney he wins
his Republican primary in Utah
big time 72% to 28% of course everyone's
going to be watching to see if and when
Romney does get to Washington as is
expected is he going to be a big Trump
critic take on the president from inside
his party or is he going to sort of go
along to get along as it relates to the
president yes who knows if mit has the
personal integrity to stand up for Trump
so fast his hair will pop off like a
little Lego man but yesterday was it all
hilarious news Staten Island saw its
worst disaster since the tracksuit store
inside the liquor store on Victory
Boulevard close in the 11th
Congressional District of New York Dan
Donovan he got Donald Trump's support
even though he voted against his tax cut
and he soundly defeated Michael Grimm
look at that 64% to 36% grim former
congressman but also former ex-con just
out of jail and trying to make a
comeback he's not an ex-con he's a
former ex-con that's a distinction only
the whitest of men can earn
and since when is jail time for a felony
political baggage it was just like a
low-key felony to like forgery or grave
borrowing to be fair I promised I was
going to give that watch back now listen
up
New York composers this story gets worse
because if I may borrow my plumbers
catchphrase there's a huge crap
explosion happening in your backyard Joe
Crowley widely thought of as a potential
future Speaker of the House was defeated
in a shocking primary loss last night
the powerful chairman of the Democratic
caucus lost by double digits the 28-year
old
Alexandria occasio Cortes a
self-described Democratic Socialist who
worked for Bernie Sanders what a
Democratic Socialist won in New York
City even this woman is screaming in
terror and she's the person who want
these results are terrifying
how did a young latina woman who wants
to abolish ice and create universal
health care win against the man who
looks like the word incumbent sounds I
guess I'm scared I hate this and I need
answers there to help unpack the meaning
of this terrifying socialist uprising is
opposition trend expert Nicole Thurmond
thank you listen Jordan as a
semi-professional Instagram influencer
with over 100 women a follower
I always know the hot new trend now I
was early on bottled water I was feeling
music way before the digital age and
Tide Pods yeah I started that why cuz
I'm a trend starter that's what I do
Jordan it's why I boarded the Trump
train in the first place
it was exciting it was new and no other
candidate was literally begging me to
stand behind him at rallies exactly yeah
you knew that the Trump team was the
winning team the disruptors not afraid
to shake things up willing to go to the
extreme Jordan you know what I'm moving
on to the next what yeah Trump is skinny
jeans I'm over it I'm onto that new cut
of denim that wide leg Queens based
democratic socialism yeah I'm getting
off the Trump train I'm getting onto the
Acacio cortes uber pool I don't know I
just I see myself in her oh well you're
gonna be a 28 year old latina democratic
social 27 Jordan I'm 27 look I go where
the eyeballs are okay Alexandria Acacio
Cortez if catching heat while Sarah
Huckabee Sanders can't even catch the
norovirus that Chipotle look trends are
cyclical okay just like locusts and
dating guys named Craig and hope its
back and America is here for it okay are
you so sure America's when you do that I
told you I did not like no you did say
that yes you did but you know what I do
like this Acacio Cortez campaign ad
women like me aren't supposed to run for
office
I wasn't born to a wealthy or powerful
family every day gets harder for working
families like mine this race is about
people versus
we've got people
it takes political courage that's why
I'm running for Congress Jordan doesn't
look at that it's someone who sticks up
for the little guy tells a personal
story of empowerment she's willing to
fight back against the system you can
see why people were drawn to this
message I am inspired to take action you
want to be a socialist no I want to be
popular dude and this is what's hot
right now so I am leaning in I've got my
progressive talking points I hired joy
Reid's blog scrubbing team I've even got
my little blazer just nice and pressed
for when I'm on MSNBC who knows how far
I'm gonna take this what are you gonna
run for office
I don't know Jordan women like me aren't
supposed to run for office but it's
never been more clear that our elected
officials aren't working for us we need
to fight for all Americans
even if they don't have a ton of
Instagram followers that shouldn't be a
barometer of success especially if
you've been working really really
freaking hard on your hashtag game
and that's why I hash tag Nichole John
Thurmond and prepared to make America
hope again damn this is gonna go
like so viral I don't know what to say
oh you know you're done talking no no
it's Nichole time now everybody you just
like and subscribe ok follow me on
Instagram YouTube Twitter match with me
on hands if you're single oh I'm still
on by the cooler than everyone the fight
continues you you a deep state operative
is sent by George Soros to take away my
second Amendment rights and force-feed
me soy burgers no well then prove it
click and subscribe and join the
opposition now